These seniors meet in a community center where they exercise to music.
Others taking a cue from college rowers in the Marina del Rey district of Los Angeles...
...engage in outdoor exercise.
Julian Myers, who was 90 years old, runs at least five kilometers a day.
Myers greets friends along his route, and says his friendships and exercise keep him active.
Other seniors enjoy the competition of lawn bowls,...
...an outdoor sport that originated in Britain.
Players try to place their balls close to a small white ball called the jack.
A 2005 study by a Netherlands researcher analyzed four decades of data...
...for more than 4,000 people,...
...finding those who exercise, increase life expectancy up to three and one-half years.
The marathon runner Myers says he's learned that seniors who stay active...
...are not distracted or slowed down by the aches and pains of aging.
Mike O'Sullivan, VOA News, Los Angeles.